Hello!
On Sunday morning, 22nd February 2026,
no one had imagined that the most wanted drug lord in the world
would be hiding in a place like this.
It was Mexico's small, mountainous tourist town,
Tapalpa.
There are stone roads,
tourist shops,
and green mountains,
but in the outer area of this beautiful town,
in the middle of the jungle,
there was a cabin complex
where El Mencho was hidden.
The
El Mencho was the man for whom the US had offered a $15 million reward.
He was so secretive that only a few photos of him were available.
He had been arrested in the 1980s and 1990s.
No one knew what he looked like today.
But on 20th February,
Mexican intelligence received an important lead.
By tracking an associate of El Mencho's romantic partner,
authorities found that the associate had taken the partner outside Tapalpa
to a secluded rural property.
This was the same secret place where El Mencho was hiding.
On 21st February, his partner left the location,
but El Mencho stayed behind with his bodyguards.
They met with El Mencho.
The couple met with Mencho at that location.
And on February 21st,
they left the building, and information was obtained that Mencho was still there.
The Mexican forces were given the opportunity they had been waiting for for years.
On 22nd February, before dawn,
the Mexican special forces, the National Guard, the Air Force, and the Army
surrounded the compound from all sides.
Without a doubt, the mission was primarily executed by ground forces.
Helicopters were used in limited numbers.
As the soldiers advanced toward the compound,
the cartel's gunmen started firing.
The security forces shot down four cartel members.
But El Mencho fled the compound with his bodyguards
and headed for a wooden cabin complex in a nearby jungle.
The security forces followed him and opened fire a second time.
Finally, the soldiers caught El Mencho in serious condition
along with two bodyguards.
He was immediately airlifted to Mexico City
but died on the way.
A former DEA chief
calls this operation one of the most significant actions in drug trafficking history.
But the story doesn't end here.
What happened after his death
was beyond anything one could imagine.
The death of this drug lord
set the whole country on fire.
But the question here is,
who was this El Mencho?
And how did his cartel become so powerful?
In 1992, in California,
the police caught a small-time drug dealer.
He was dealing in heroin.
He was sent to jail and later deported.
But no one thought that this man
would become the most wanted drug lord in the world twenty years later.
This story begins in 1966,
in the city of Aguililla in Michoacán State, Mexico.
This was an area where poverty was at its peak
and where illegal marijuana plantations were hidden in the mountains.
El Mencho was born Nemesio Jose Guerra Cervantes.
His family were avocado farmers.
He left school in the 5th grade to help his family.
He started his career in farming.
But by the time he turned 14,
he was in charge of marijuana fields.
In the 1980s,
in search of a better life,
he went to America
and moved to California.
He had dreamed of the Great American Dream.
But instead of a better life,
he found a life of crime in America.
In 1986, the San Francisco Police arrested him for theft
and for possession of a loaded gun.
Officers suspected that he was a meth dealer.
After a few years of hiding and stealing,
in 1992, at the San Francisco Imperial Bar,
undercover cops caught him selling heroin.
He was sentenced to three years in prison.
It was in January 1997
that Mencho was released on parole.
He was then deported back to Mexico.
He was 30 years old at the time.
And this is where the story takes a major twist.
After returning to Mexico,
Mencho became a police officer.
You heard that right.
A convicted drug dealer
became a police officer.
He worked for the police for a few years.
And during these years,
he understood the inner workings of the force.
He understood how easily the Mexican police could be bought with a small amount of money.
He saw how much an officer would sell his soul for.
And he saw exactly where the holes in the system were.
This knowledge was going to become one of his most dangerous weapons.
During this time, he married Rosalinda Gonzalez Valencia,
a woman who came from a powerful cartel family.
This marriage became his entry ticket into organized crime.
In the beginning, he became a bodyguard and hitman for the Valencia family's Milenio Cartel.
But by 2010, all the leaders of that cartel were either killed or in jail.
Mencho asked for leadership, but he didn't get it.
So he broke away and formed his own group.
He founded the Cártel de Jalisco Nueva Generación, or CJNG. Fast forward five years later to 1st May 2015, the Mexican military launched Operation Jalisco to capture El Mencho.
Military helicopters were used,
but the CJNG already knew about it.
Cartel gunmen were armed with RPG-27 rocket launchers and heavy machine guns.
When helicopters arrived to attack the cartel,
they used those rocket launchers and machine guns to shoot them down.
We heard a boom like a bomb. They took down the aircraft. They shot it down.
Only 9 out of 18 people survived.
Even those were seriously wounded.
Think about it, a drug cartel shot down a military helicopter.
This cartel was so powerful that later on, in different areas of Mexico,
they set fire to dozens of buses, trucks, and gas stations.
The Mexican government had to send 10,000 troops to control the situation.
A federal investigator even said that since the time of Pablo Escobar,
a drug mafia had never had such a direct and violent confrontation with the authorities.
Thank you.
You are the power of the world.
Yes, you are the power of the world.
But the question is, how did this CJNG become so powerful?
The answer lies in two chemicals:
Methamphetamine and fentanyl.
CJNG was not an ordinary drug cartel.
It operated like a paramilitary force.
According to DEA estimates,
of all the drugs entering America by air and sea in 2019,
at least one-third belonged to this single cartel.
By 2018, CJNG had more than 100 meth labs in Mexico.
The profit margins for meth were many times higher than those for cocaine and heroin.
And most importantly,
while Colombian suppliers had to depend on coca plants,
meth could be manufactured independently
by importing chemicals from China.
Some experts estimate that CJNG's war chest was worth more than $20 billion.
The entire port system of Mexico,
specifically the Port of Manzanillo,
was under the control of this cartel.
The raw materials imported from China through this port
were used to manufacture meth.
There is an interesting pattern in this story.
CJNG controlled the Port of Manzanillo
because everything was available from a single access point.
Chemicals, logistics, and the supply chain
were all in one place.
And this principle of a single access point
is what I applied while creating the AI Fiesta.
Many of you have been using AI Fiesta for a while now.
But for those who don't know,
AI Fiesta is a platform
where the top 10 AI models in the world,
like ChatGPT, Gemini, Claude, Grok, DeepSeek, Qwen, Perplexity, Llama, and more,
are all available in one place.
One subscription, one interface.
We have improved significantly over the last few months.
The speed of the platform has increased,
new features like Memory have been added,
and the platform has become more reliable.
But the biggest update so far
was launched a few days ago:
Image Studio.
The world's top image generation AIs are now in one place.
Imagine you need a professional photo,
but you don't have a photographer or a camera.
You can do it with one click through Image Studio.
Something like this.
It is possible to generate hyper-realistic images
without any watermarks.
You can also compare images from the world's top AI models side by side.
From Google's models
to China's best image generation models,
like SeeDream, you can find them all.
You can work with every tool
and select the image you like best.
Not only that, if you want to edit images,
we have also added a built-in editor to the website.
Whether it is to remove a background,
upscale an image,
change the style,
or add elements,
everything is possible in one place.
To make things easier,
we have added templates.
You can create a professional photo shoot with just one click.
You can redecorate your room
or try on a new hairstyle.
And while you use it,
your images are never used for data training.
Your privacy is completely protected,
unlike many free AI apps.
Try it for yourself.
You can find the link to AI Fiesta in the description and pinned comment.
And if you buy the annual plan for AI Fiesta,
you will get a huge discount via that same link.
But don't delay,
because it is a limited-time offer.
And remember, this is just version 1.0 of Image Studio.
In the future, we will make it even more powerful and useful.
As a small teaser,
in the next few months,
we will add agentic capabilities to AI Fiesta.
Now, let's get back to the topic.
But more dangerous than meth,
there was another product that CJNG made its future.
A product that was so deadly
that a person's life could be ended with just 2 mg.
I will talk about this in the next video.
But before that, the question is:
how did the cartels in Mexico become so powerful
that they could collide with the government?
Imagine a Mexican mayor
whose salary is 30,000 pesos a month.
One night, an SUV arrives at his house.
The cartel men are sitting inside.
In one hand is a briefcase
with 500,000 pesos in it.
And in the other hand is a gun.
The cartel men give the Mayor a choice: Plata o Plomo.
It means either take the money
or take the bullet.
This is not an imaginary story.
This scenario is repeated every week and every month
in hundreds of cities across Mexico.
How do you think this system was established?
It was founded by a political party,
the PRI.
It was called the Institutional Revolutionary Party in English.
This party ruled Mexico for 71 years
as a single-party state.
From 1929 to 2000,
the central government under the PRI was so weak
that instead of ending organized crime,
it started making deals with them.
This was called the Plaza System.
The rules were very simple: the cartels would limit public violence, they wouldn't threaten PRI officials, and in return, everyone from mayors to governors would be given a mordida,
which means a bribe.
Imagine,
the entire country was essentially on a weekly payroll.
In the year 2000, when the PRI's reign ended,
the entire system was shattered.
In 2006, President Felipe Calderón
declared war on the cartels.
I say this is a fight of all Mexicans, because criminals don't discriminate.
They hurt all of society.
Thousands of soldiers were deployed,
and with the help of the US,
25 of Mexico's top 37 drug kingpins were killed or arrested.
But the problem with this war on drugs was that
if one drug leader was killed, another would take his place.
If one kingpin was removed, two more would emerge.
This led to the birth of smaller and more dangerous gangs.
They toppled drug kingpins and hit cartels so hard that many shattered into smaller, ultra-violent gangs.
Because of the increasing violence, Andrés Manuel López Obrador became president in 2018.
He is known as AMLO.
He introduced a new slogan: Hugs Not Bullets.
Meaning that they would not use bullets, but would clean the system with empathy.
He said that if we stop fighting with cartels and end poverty and unemployment, then crime will automatically reduce.
We will change the failed strategy of combating insecurity and violence.
Rather than using force,
we will address the root causes of insecurity and violence.
But unfortunately, the implementation failed.
Neither did the war work, nor did the root causes get the attention they needed.
And there was something else behind it.
The most shocking thing about this whole story is that
while Americans were the victims of the drug trade,
America was also the architect of the drug crisis itself.
And this was not because of one mistake,
but a chain of repeated mistakes
where America continually shot itself in the foot.
In the early 1980s,
the CIA supported Contra rebels against the socialist government of Nicaragua.
The Contras received training and money through Mexican drug cartels.
The Washington Post exposed in July 1990
how the CIA trained Contra rebels at the ranch of Mexico's biggest drug lord,
Rafael Caro Quintero, near Veracruz.
The CIA was openly using the property of a drug trafficker.
This was not a conspiracy theory.
It was proven in a US Senate investigation,
in the Kerry Committee Report of April 1989.
America helped make these drug cartels powerful to serve its political agenda.
And today, they have become its biggest enemy.
Second was NAFTA in 1994,
the North American Free Trade Agreement.
According to this, trade restrictions between the US, Canada, and Mexico were reduced.
There were officials who warned
that NAFTA would open the border for drugs.
They were silenced in Congressional debates.
Before this trade agreement,
around 7,500 trucks would pass through the border in a day.
But after this,
it increased to 12,000 trucks.
It was physically impossible to check every truck.
So, the drug trade increased even more.
America opened a highway for drugs.
NAFTA had another dangerous side effect.
America started dumping its cheap crops in Mexico.
Corn prices for Mexican farmers fell by more than 65%.
Between 1991 and 2007,
around 2 million farmers had to leave their farms in Mexico.
And these unemployed farmers became the foot soldiers of the drug cartels.
The third issue is weapons.
Between 2014 and 2018,
70% of the firearms recovered in Mexico were American.
There are 6,700 gun dealers in the border region.
That is 3 gun dealers per mile.
The Mexican government estimates that every year,
200,000 firearms are smuggled from America.
The fourth point is the most absurd.
Under Operation Fast and Furious, American agencies
deliberately allowed more than 2,000 weapons to flow into Mexico.
The US agencies intended to track these guns
to reach criminal organizations.
But they lost track of the weapons.
And later, these guns were used against Americans.
So, here you understand the role of America.
First, let the cartels grow,
then open the border,
and then send in more than 200,000 guns.
Then, when people start dying from these guns,
send 2,000 more guns saying that this is part of a plan.
Abhishek Bachchan used to have such useless plans in the film Dhoom.
We make him rob again.
Now, let's come back to the product I mentioned earlier,
the product that CJNG saw as its future.
This is Fentanyl.
Fentanyl is a synthetic opioid.
It is a very dangerous drug
that is 50 times more powerful than heroin.
Imagine a few grains of sand on your palm.
This small amount, only 2 mg,
is enough to kill a person.
And the economics are even more incredible.
Producing a fentanyl pill costs 10 cents,
which is about 8 to 9 rupees.
Yet, this pill is sold for between 10 and 30 dollars,
or 1,000 to 3,000 rupees.
A drug cartel's production costs
might be only 50,000 dollars,
but they can earn up to $20 million.
the impact was shocking.
In 2023, approximately
73,000 drug overdose deaths in America
were caused by synthetic opioids.
About 70% of these deaths were caused by fentanyl.
If you remember travel content creator Ananya Sood,
according to US authorities,
her death was caused by an accidental fentanyl overdose. You can imagine how serious this issue is and how terrifying the effects of this drug are. In the fentanyl crisis, CJNG played a major role. In 2013, El Mencho's son, El Menchito, said
that he wanted to build a fentanyl empire.
This was right before the fentanyl epidemic hit America.
In September 2024,
a US court found El Menchito guilty.
And in March 2025,
he was sentenced to life imprisonment.
His son was in jail,
but at that point, the father was still free.
Until the morning of 22nd February 2026.
In the operation I described at the beginning of the video,
El Mencho was killed after sustaining injuries.
But as soon as the news of his death spread,
the CJNG caused chaos throughout Mexico.
A senior leader of the cartel, El Tuli,
who was El Mencho's right-hand man,
ordered coordinated attacks.
He offered 20,000 Mexican pesos to every soldier,
a bounty of approximately $1,100.
Think about how strange it is for a cartel to put a bounty on the soldiers of its own country's army.
After this, cartel gunmen set fires in 20 different states.
Cars were burned, highways were blocked,
businesses were destroyed,
more than 250 roadblocks were erected,
schools were closed,
and flights were cancelled.
Mexico's second-largest city, Guadalajara, became a ghost town.
Breaking news coming in from Mexico.
Guadalajara is witnessing unusual scenes tonight, with large parts of the city appearing almost deserted amid rising tensions.
Security analysts say that the violent response of CJNG members shows signs of narco-terrorism.
This could be a scenario like Colombia in the 1980s, when Pablo Escobar waged war against the state.
This is a challenge to the Mexican state.
It seems that all the main CJNG commanders
are attacking the Mexican state together.
They are attacking their own country.
According to some security analysts,
if the cartel is trying to avenge this operation,
then a total war against the Mexican state could begin.
Now the question is, what will happen next?
El Mencho's line of succession has broken.
His son is in jail in America.
His wife was arrested on money laundering charges in Mexico in November 2021.
His two brothers are also languishing in Mexican jails.
The remaining four CJNG commanders could now be the subjects of a succession war.
In America, the Trump administration has declared cartels
as foreign terrorist organizations.
And it hasn't stopped at just declarations.
In September 2025, the American military did something unprecedented.
They started dropping bombs on alleged drug trafficking vessels.
Under Operation Southern Spear,
at least 150 people have been killed in 44 strikes.
America is dropping bombs on boats in the open sea
without evidence or trial.
To every terrorist, thug, smuggler, and poisoner bringing drugs
into the United States of America,
please be warned that we will blow you out of existence.
We have no choice.
According to human rights groups,
this is illegal under international law,
and many of the victims were civilian fishermen.
On 9th January, Trump said on Fox News that
he would also attack the cartels on land.
We are going to start hitting the cartels
on land soon.
The cartels are running Mexico.
It is very sad to watch and see what's happened to that country.
And the US Defense Secretary has also called the cartels the Al-Qaeda of the Western Hemisphere.
This is why pressure on Mexican President Claudia Sheinbaum to take action against the cartels is rising.
El Mencho's killing was the biggest success for her government.
She wanted to show that Mexico could fight the cartels on its own,
without the need for American forces.
But the real question here is:
will the drug cartels finally end in Mexico after all this?
History shows that every time a drug lord leaves Mexico,
two more appear in his place.
In reality, the solution lies in addressing the root causes.
As long as there is demand in America,
Mexico will provide the supply.
As long as American guns cross the border into Mexico,
the Mexican cartels will continue to fight.
As long as the cartels pay more than the monthly salary of local police officers,
corruption will not stop.
As long as the raw materials for fentanyl and meth come from China,
the supply chain will not break.
This is not just a problem for Mexico or America alone.
It is a shared crisis,
and its solution must be shared as well.
A few months later, in June 2026,
four FIFA World Cup matches were scheduled to take place in Mexico.
It is the world's largest sporting event
in the territory of the most dangerous cartel in the world.
Hey, Mexico!
Mexico!
This is the story of a drug lord
who almost took the entire government into his own hands.
But this doesn't happen only in Mexico.
There was a man in America
who had some of the world's most powerful people,
including Presidents, Prime Ministers, Princes, and billionaires,
in his grasp.
His name was Jeffrey Epstein.
Epstein's story is even more disturbing than that of the Mexican drug cartels
because he did not just engage in crime,
he blackmailed the entire system.
You can learn the whole story by clicking on this video.
And don't forget to download AI Fiesta.
The link is in the description.
Thank you very much.